this used to be a road until it
disappeared underwater mid last year now
the only way to get around in this part
of south sudan is by boats and canoes
it's the worst flood this region has
seen in 60 years in this area every home
is abandoned
families had no choice but to leave
people like noel mccoy who arrived here
in july her children and extended family
now sleep in this makeshift house not
sure if and when they will be able to go
back home
my house is still under water there are
a lot of snakes and reptiles the place
is still a river it's no longer home so
how can i go back
the landscape has changed there is now
more water and less dry land the united
nations says close to 800 000 people
have been affected
many of them can only be reached by boat
they urgently need shelter clean water
and have to rely on food rations from
humanitarian agencies even before
the effects of this climate change
crisis even before that because of the
ongoing conflict in south sudan people
were already food insecure
before climate change there was about 50
to 60 percent of the population in need
of food assistance now with this extreme
weather patterns
there's about 70 to 75 so we're seeing a
decline in people's ability to put food
on the table and to feed their children
and it is unfortunately a ticking bomb
flood waters have destroyed crops
blocked access to fields and reduced
grazing land last year this area was dry
there were a few homes and animals here
then it started to rain and it began to
flood people built this dike to try and
keep the water back and some of them had
to move over this side to start over
this country is no stranger to floods
but they are now becoming more frequent
when you get displaced people like now
we have in mangala
they are also having a lot of issues
with
the
host communities because those people
are coming with their livestock and
these people are agriculture agriculture
so there's a lot of conflict so this
impact of climate change is now going to
make us have internally displaced people
even refugees
not from
armed conflict but from the impacts of
climate it's the third straight year of
severe flooding of the white nile in
south sudan after unusually high
rainfall in upstream countries health
officials fear an increase in waterborne
diseases including malaria
people out here are saying they need
help and they need it fast
hari mutasa al jazeera jungle a state
south sudan